[Music]
do you remember the Newton's first law
of motion it says that an object will
continue to do what it's doing unless
acted upon by an unbalanced force or
some net force now the important
question is what happens when there is
net force acting on an object that's
precisely what the second law of motion
will discuss do you remember
understanding the first law of motion
with a simple diagram if the forces are
balanced the acceleration will be zero
in the first case the object will
continue to remain at rest and in the
second the object will continue to stay
in motion at the same velocity and in
the same direction don't forget these
two cases will remain true only if the
forces are balanced only if the net
force is zero now let's try to create a
similar diagram for the second case if
the forces are unbalanced then there
will be acceleration we saw that in the
previous video and now we come to the
interesting part let me ask you a
question and I'm sure you can answer it
on which two factors do you think the
acceleration will depend on I want you
to tax your brain a bit
let me repeat my question on which two
factors do you think will the
acceleration depend on okay let's say
doesn't operate on a table you apply a
net force of 10 units on it and then you
apply a net force of 20 units on it in
which case do you think the acceleration
will be more of course the one in which
the force was more so we can say that
one of the things the acceleration
depends on is net force if it's more
then more will be the acceleration if
it's less then lesser will be the
acceleration acceleration depends
directly on the net force come on now I
want you to think about the second
quantity the acceleration will depend on
let's say there are two objects on the
table one has a mass of three kilograms
Theodore has a mass of five kilograms
now if we apply net force of ten units
to each of them which one do you think
will accelerate more surely it's the
three Kage you want because it has
lesser mass less of the mass more the
acceleration and more the mass lesser
the acceleration hence we can say that
acceleration depends inversely on the
object's mass if you understand this
concept well then understanding the
second law of motion will be very easy
mathematically it can be written like
this in simple terms the acceleration is
directly proportional to the net force
applied and inversely proportional to
the mass of the object that's the second
law or as more people understand it like
this the net force is a product of mass
and acceleration with this can you tell
me the units of force that should be
easy
the standard unit of mass is kilograms
and that of acceleration is meters per
second squared so the unit of force is
kilograms times meters per second
squared and this is what we call F
Newton one Newton is one kilogram times
meters per second square so if the mass
of the object is ten kilograms and the
acceleration is 10 meters per second
squared then the force will equal 100
Newton's we can say that one Newton is
defined as the amount of force required
to give a 1 kilogram mass and
acceleration of 1 meter per second
square
[Music]